in this lesson we're going to talk about
direct variation equation so what is the
direct variation equation how do we set
it up how do we solve it that's we're
going to talk about in this lesson so
the key phrase that you'll notice is
that it will say something like Y varies
directly with X or the pressure varies
directly with the volume or something to
that effect you're gonna see varies
directly with and the way you set that
up is y equals 80 times x or y equals K
times X you have this a value or this K
value that's called the constant of
proportionality and what it is you know
it's the quantity that relates the two
variables together now when you look at
a direct variation equation it's a line
okay and it goes right through the
origin off the constant of variation if
it's positive it's going to be going up
to the right if it's negative is going
to be going down to the right but it's
always going to be going through the
origin like that when it's a direct
variation equation so that's how you set
it up okay that's just a general
equation but they're going to give you
some values to help you to solve for
that cast net variation to get a more
specific equation that you can then use
to solve other problems so let's go
through an example once you pause the
video see if you can do it on your own
and we'll go through it together so see
if you remember how to do this if Y
varies directly with x and y equals eat
when x equals negative to find out what
Y is when x equals 5 okay so let's see
if you can do this one on your own what
i would do here is I would say okay y
varies directly with axe so I'm setting
up my general equation and it tells you
when y is 8 when X is negative 2 that
helps me to solve for a so i'm going to
divide both sides by negative 2 so you
can see that a equals negative 4 you
take that negative for you put it back
in for a now we have a more specific
equation that we can use to solve the
second part of this a problem here it
says fine y when x equals 5 okay so I'm
just going to put five in for X so y
equals negative 4 times 5 so you can see
that y equals negative 20 and you got it
so direct variation equations may just
be like one problem on the s80 that you
know is related to this but it's
something that's helpful to know you
just want to make sure you remember this
basic setup here
the general form of the equation solve
for your constant of variation now you
have a more specific equation that you
can then use to solve you no further
questions so review this lesson if you
need to otherwise they'll see you in the
next lesson